hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my heroes reborn episodes one
and two video now there's 13 episodes
total and they did the first two
episodes as part of this premiere so I
think there's just gonna be going for 12
more weeks
the premise is actually pretty
interesting even though it takes a
little while to get going so try to
explain what some of the technical
conspiracy theories that are going on
through these different storylines
eventually they'll all converge by the
finale just like the original series
everything is connected through this
Renata's conspiracy but only a couple of
the characters have started to figure
out what's going on so let's get going
just careful for spoilers for the first
two episodes if you haven't seen them
yet here we go starting with top 10
moments the world goes to [ __ ] the
premise of the opening act is that it
picks up years after the original series
left off people with powers are now like
an open thing if people know all about
Evo's that's what they're calling them
but it is just you know stand in for
mutants metahumans whatever you want to
call them primatech paper the evil
corporation that hrg used to work for in
the original series seems a little more
positive when things pick up
Renata's seems like the evil
organization so big explosion goes off
causes a huge tragedy they blame
Mohinder from the original series who's
a big proponent for evo rights and it
becomes this x-men Days of Future past
situation this darkest timeline where
being an Evo becomes a really bad thing
they start getting hunted down by a
shadow conspiracy which i think is
Renatus everything seems to be pointing
towards this weird evil corporate giant
creating this mystery product that's
powered by people with superpowers so
I'll talk about that later that's gonna
be really important using super-powered
people to create a product on to number
nine Chuck season six the darkest Chuck
so Zachary Levi seems like he might be
the Sylar of this series he actually
this is really dark opening where he
kills all those people in that church
however later we find out that it was
his son and wife that died during that
Odessa tragedy so he's kind of a
sympathetic villain especially when he
runs into Peter Pan in the ice-cream
shop yes it does seem like he's trying
to hunt down and kill these people but I
think they left a back door for him to
turn good when he starts to figure out
that he's not getting credit for the
things that he's doing he reads the
paper and learns that someone's trying
to pin everything on Mohinder Suresh I
think that's also going to be someone
connected to Renatus so it just leaves
the door open for Zachary Levi's
character tour
with the heroes to take down Renata's
because we're not as they're probably
the people that are secretly responsible
for his wife and child's death for that
original tragedy and that's the whole
reason that he's hunting these Evo's
down because he thinks that they are
responsible so when he finds out that
it's actually evil corporation he'll
probably stop trying to kill people on
to number eight meet Peter Pan
teleporting ice-cream fanatic he played
Peter Pan on once upon a time so I'm
just gonna call him Peter Pan for now
cuz that's probably what you're thinking
when you're watching him I'm thinking of
him is taking the spot that Claire had
in the original series he's like the new
cheerleader to the series let the young
character the young people that are
watching the show get attached to
anytime there's a show with a bunch of
adults on it and they want kids to watch
it too they put a kid on the show so
he's the new high school kid and his
ability allows him to teleport things to
wherever he thinks of but I think what
we'll find the twist is with that is
that he has to have been to these places
before he has to have a memory of them
but once all the heroes come together
he's probably gonna be there rapid
transit system I will say I totally like
his character more than I liked the
cheerleader character is especially
considering the role they serve in the
narrative the cast around him to at that
high school is actually pretty cool to
look like the jock who is a dick because
he gets abused at home I love you so
much man thanks for getting rid of my
stepdad his new sidekick also very
lovable character I love the fact that
they use the ice-cream shop it actually
reminds me of the pie store from Pushing
Daisies one of my favorite scenes too is
when he sees Zachary Levi sitting at the
table just goes you know walks right up
to him and Zachary Levi was like oh my
god what's going on I don't understand
he had just been talking about tracking
down and killing that little boy on to
number seven the legend of el vengador
this is a really nice arc about this
post-traumatic stress soldier who
doesn't seem like he has superpowers
like we don't know that yet but it seems
like the brother was the one with
superpowers and his son I'm guessing
this guy does not which is what's gonna
make him more of a hero in that he does
not have superpowers but he still tries
to do superhero things the priest mist
based powers actually pretty cool too
you can see how the little kids power is
gonna come in handy too getting into and
getting out of locked rooms the way the
writers designed everyone's powers is so
that they're just really critical to the
story of how they save the world so
think about what each person's power is
and how they might be able to use that
to take down Renata
speaking of problem-solving on to number
six the mystery of the evernow' game in
the sword if you didn't recognize it
this is totally hero's sword from the
original series so heroes plug in a show
up as part of this arc he's one of the
other original characters that came back
for this series in that yamato company
also probably connected to or not us
they they probably developed some of the
machinery behind whatever they're doing
katana girl's father seems like the
person who wrote that comic book based
on the game that's really instructions
for how to save him the weird thing is
is that her storyline gets into this
cyberpunk territory where it's like how
does the sword transport her into a game
like what's the difference between the
world of the game in the real world is
she transporting herself digitally like
is it a digital thing maybe that has
something to do with her power but just
remember the idea of digital
consciousness in cyberpunk that was like
a big thing in the 90s if you ever read
tad Williams other land I kind of think
some of that is going on in this heroes
reborn storyline whereby a bunch of
people are trying to ascend to a higher
reality using digital technology onto
number five welcome back Haitian so this
is kind of unfortunate that he dies so
quickly but it's fun to see him again
especially the hrg related humor he has
this very Coulson like sense of humor
where it's like he's a very dark
character did you get some office work
place based comedy have I been here
before I don't know have you been here
before the weirdness though that they
haven't explained yet is is why did HRG
ask the Haitian to erase his memory
about the tragedy at Odessa
maybe because Renatus wants information
this in HR G's brain and if the Haitian
were to erase it then they wouldn't be
able to get it that'd be the only reason
for a hero like a good person to want to
erase their mind I think he got his mind
erased to protect everyone going a
little bit deeper though number four
primatech paper still very much active
on level five if you go back to the
original series you remember like part
of the mystery of primatech paper is is
that you know like on the ground level
there's this paper company that does
these weird evil abduction things but
gradually through the series they led us
down into deeper and deeper levels we're
like the further down you win the bigger
the conspiracy got the crazier things
were so level 5 is just like the
the beast and as we know Renata's bought
out primatech paper after the tragedy so
those people down in the basement that
Zachary Levi killed those are all
Renata's people trying to use primate
x-files to find all these power people
to use them to power their device the
device is called epic monster number
three some of the creepy looking
villains aren't actually villains cute
creepy trenchcoat guy so this character
here typically plays pedophiles like the
worst people you could possibly imagine
whenever he shows up in TV shows so
naturally the twist is is that he's
trying to help Peter Pan save the world
for me he is actually like the new hrg
of this series if you remember in the
original series
HRG was actually kind of a bad guy like
he started out as a villain that turned
into one of the anti heroes of the show
I mean he's still kind of bad because he
still attracts people down beats the
crap out of him but now HRG is more of a
straight up good guy so you have like
another mystery guy who seems like a
villain who ends up being something of a
friend wants number two the mystery of
Molly Walker the fuel in this epic
engine that Renatus is trying to build
so Molly Walker red head trying to get
away with some money gets entrapped by
the people at the casino who probably
end up working for Renatus her storyline
was kind of a reverse Peter Pan
situation whereby someone that seemed
totally genuine ended up being super
creepy and creepy trenchcoat guy for
Peter Pan ended up being a good guy and
the really awesome thing here is that
this big MacGuffin of the epic machine
is definitely the MacGuffin right now it
needs to launch in the next couple of
days which I am so happy about it means
we're not gonna have to wait for forever
for this they can't do that until they
plug Molly Walker into it whatever
that's gonna end up looking like it's
probably like some Total Recall
situation where they plug her into a
giant machine and finally on to my
number one WTF moment the epic machine
that Renatus is building looks like it
is either going to forcibly physically
evolve the human race or it's going to
digitally evolve them like it's gonna be
a matrix like situation that ties in
with the video game we don't have quite
enough information to form a complete
hypothesis about what Renatus is trying
to do it but I think the way the series
is plotted out we'll have enough clues
after the next one or two episodes there
was also this one disconnected scene up
near the North Pole it looked like it
was the North Pole of the girl that
looked
she was manipulating the Northern Lights
in this black hole looking event in the
sky and I think this is happening in the
real world so it seems like whatever
Renatus is doing is like a physical
astrological phenomenon the weird thing
though the weird thing in all this is
that the guy who died that HRG was
talking to said that they found a way to
monetize Evo's so this could be some
sort of like evil version of Google or
Apple just trying to earn a lot of money
I'm hoping that's not the case I'm
hoping it's something grander like
people are trying to forcibly evolve the
human race you guys let me know in the
comments just based on the information
we have right now what do you think that
Renata says epic machine is going to do
to the human race is it gonna be
something that's gonna like put them
into some sort of altered matrix reality
or is it just gonna like biologically
evolve the human race and everyone will
be an Evo the only thing in these first
two episodes that I think didn't work
really well where the Japanese like
video game sequences like that character
it feels kind of it odds with the rest
of the show like the rest of the
characters feel like normal people but
she almost feels like she's a digital
character that's been pushed into
reality we just haven't had enough
scenes with her to create that context
she feels more like a device to push the
plot forward than an actual character
but that's actually another good
question who's your guys favorite
character so far I do like Peter Pan
teleporter just because they seem so
earnest saccharine Levi's kind of fun
being an antihero kind of antagonist
right now HRG still totally awesome he's
like the glue that holds the show
together right now
he's like the backbone of the plot he's
the one that ties everything together
because he goes back to old-school
primatech and a lot of the stories being
told from his perspective
so because I'm liking the show so far
I'm gonna do videos for each of the
episodes I'll give it to at least like
Episode four like two more weeks
we can always reevaluate if the show
starts to fall apart around like Episode
five or six he feels like this show is
actually designed to be binge watched in
like one 13 hour sitting as opposed to
like a weekly show so I think when it's
all over it'll actually be even better
when you just watch it marathon style
it's just that some shows that do that
save a lot of the big payoff for the
last couple of episodes and that doesn't
work as well when you're airing things
once a week but there's actually quite a
bit of TV coming back in the next week
so agents of shield starts next week
I'll be doing videos for that just like
normal I just posted a new trailer video
you can click here to watch that and you
can click here for my first episode from
Gotham's
- that just started this week - so
thanks so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow